dr anthony fauci under fire from critics
who are now
accusing him of taking credit for
operation warp speed
watch this when i saw what happened
in new york city almost overrunning of
our health care system it was like
oh my goodness and that's when it became
very clear
that the decision we made on january the
10th
to go all out and develop a vaccine may
have been the best decision
that i've ever made with regard to an
intervention as the director of the
institute
dana let's just see where we can agree
here because i think we can agree that
operation warp speed started
under president trump and i'd also say
that
it was dr fauci who had the knowledge to
get
warp speed going when it did
while trump was down playing covet 19.
do we agree or not
well i i'm going to agree with half of
what you said which is that operation
warp speed is great
i would imagine that it was found she
was like you know we ought to really do
this
but it was president trump and fauci has
said over and over that was like
absolutely let's do it and then he was
the one trump
uh pushing the company saying yeah five
years that's not good enough for me i
want this done in a year
and then they were able to do it so but
when i looked at the full context of his
comments i it doesn't bother me that
much that he's talking about
his role in this i do think that um you
know you don't have to say yes to every
interview there are so many interviews
happening
uh and i would look to actually the new
cdc director under biden
uh rachel wolinski rochelle balinsky who
basically
she's begging everybody to be more
afraid
going into april and there's i mean
i i just don't see that happening i've
been out traveling a little bit i've
been out and about i mean people feel
like
they're ready to get back to normal so i
don't know how that's going to go
jesse also in this uh interview of
former trump doctors dr
deborah burks who was a trump appointee
says
400 000 of the 500 hundred thousand
lives have been lost could have been
saved if trump had taken
quicker action what's your thought
yeah maybe we could have taken action in
2019
then no lives would have been lost i'd
asked chyna about that one
but fauci's claim is about as wild as
his first pitch
i think this is a little bit of legacy
fluffing here
this would be like saying jfk doesn't
deserve any credit for putting a man on
the moon
it was a career bureaucrat at nasa
he was the one who really did it this
was the biggest
multi-agency effort ever in
modern day history it wasn't just the
nih
under fouchy you're not going to give dr
han any credit at fda or redfield at cdc
or azar
who oversees fauci at hhs
or what about all of the regulators and
how about the military
that did all the distribution donald
trump placed a huge
bet on these companies by pre-ordering
all of these 200 million doses 200
million doses that are still being
administered
joe biden hasn't administered any of his
own doses he's still working
off trump inventory so this was
something that was
very aggressive this timeline and they
cut a lot of red
tape and they gave 4.5
billion to moderna and pfizer so to sit
back and say
oh it was all me fauci's a lot of things
a team player not one of them
all right so tucker you know trump's own
poster said he thinks the reason trump
lost the election was his fumbling
handling
of the covet situation do you think that
failure is not going to become trump's
legacy
oh whatever first of all i don't care
who gets credit
it's interesting watching fauci and
sanjay gupta they're both tv doctors
wish dr oz had been there but i actually
think fauci is the least credible on the
screen